TONIGHT."
>> Tucker: YOU REMEMBER THE
CANADIAN SHOP TEACHER 2 PULLED
THE KIDS IN HIS CLASS INTO HIS
WEIRD SEXUAL FETISHES -- SHOWED
UP IN ENORMOUS PROSTHETIC
BREASTS AND WAVED THEM AT THE
KIDS.
FOR MONTHS THE SCHOOL BOARD
DEFENDERED THIS CREEP.
NOW UNDER THE THREAT OF LEGAL
ACTION FROM PARENTS THEY ARE
BACKING DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
THE SCHOOL BOARD WILL REQUIRE
A PROFESSIONAL DRESS CODE FOR
TEACHERS.
MEANING SMALLER PROSTHETIC
BREASTS.
THE CANADIAN MEDIA IGNORED THIS
STORY.
REBEL NEWS IS DID NOT.
DAVID HAS BEEN ON IT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
YOU LOOK GREAT BY THE WAY.
>> [LAUGHING].
AS THEY SAY, GIVE THEM THE
JIGGLE WITH THE GIGGLE.
>> Tucker: AS LONG AS YOU FEEL
EMPOWERED WE ARE FOR IT.
SINCE YOU ARE WEARING THE
COSTUME OF THE SHOP TEACHER IN
ONTARIO, COULD YOU TEACH SHOP
CLASS WEARING THOSE THINGS?
>> OH, TUCKER, YOU COULD NOT.
I SAID FORGET ABOUT THE MINISTRY
OF EDUCATION.
WHERE THE MINISTRY OF LABOR.
THIS BREAKING NEWS EVERY SHOP
ETIQUETTE RULE IN THE BOOK.
IN CASE YOUR AUDIENCE THINKS I
ATTACHED MYSELF TO A FETISH
LIFESTYLE.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
I WENT THERE TO THE HALTOM
DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD IN OCTOBER
DRESSED LIKE BUSTY LEMIEUX.
THE SHEER BLOUSE AND THE NIPPLES
AND THE BLOND HAIR AND BIKE
SHORTS.
THEY ARE ALL DOWN WITH THE
RADICAL TRANSGENDER AGENDA BUT
ONLY WHEN IT'S IN FRONT OF THE
KIDS.
WHEN IT'S FRONT OF THEIR SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING, THEY FLED THE
ROOM.
I HAVE BEEN BANNED FOR LIFE FROM
THE SCHOOL BOARD HEAD-TO-HEAD --
HEADQUARTERS BECAUSE I WAS
ASKING IMPOLITE QUESTIONS.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF DRAG
WHEN IT COMES TO THEM.
EARLIER THIS MONTH THE TRUSTEES
APPROVED THE REQUEST OF THE
EDUCATION DIRECTOR.
THEY WANT TO CRAFT
A PROFESSIONALISM POLICY FOR
STANDARDS OF DRESS IN THE CLASS
ROOMS.
MAYBE THE VIEWERS ARE SAYING
ISN'T THIS DEJU-VU?
DIDN'T THEY LOOK INTO THIS BACK
IN NOVEMBER?
YES, THEY DID.
IT WAS REJECTED IN NOVEMBER.
BY THE HUMAN RESOURCES
SUPERINTENDENT.
TWO THINGS, TUCKER, WHAT WOULD
CHANGE FROM NOVEMBER UNTIL
MARCH?
I DON'T THINK ANYTHING HAS.
AND ALSO THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION, HE RELEASED
A STATEMENT WHERE HE SAID THAT
HE MIGHT VETO A DRESS CODE
RECOMMENDATION, THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ANSWERABLE TO
HUMAN RIGHTS, EQUITY AND ETC.
IT'S LIKE PROFESSIONAL
WRESTLING.
NOTHING CAN REAL.
>> Tucker: WE WILL HAVE TO VISIT
YOUR COUNTRY.
I AM INTIMIDATED BY YOUR
PROSTHETIC BREASTS AND MAY NEED
TO FLEE.
I APPRECIA